what has been your biggest help
balancing and successful career marriage
and five kids and being a producing
partner with your wife which most people
would probably be divorced if they were
producing and writing Partners yeah well
what I would say is that you know the
joke is that I do it very poorly but I
would say that it's a constant
evaluation and
it's
um
you know it's like you you also have to
understand it's like my wife
is was kind of is my writing partner
right so but like when she has a brain
tumor or she's writing a book or we're
dealing with essentially five kids that
are like teenagers it's like how much
writing
should even be the priority you know
what I mean or should I you know
relish the access that I get to it that
I do
um but it is I would say the answer to
that
it's a constant evaluation every three
months
I mean it's ongoing where my wife's like
you know every script I uh you know she
reads everything that I'm gonna do and
she'll be like this is not worth it
this is not worth it and I'll be like
all right you know I mean it's yeah it's
a partnership and she's usually right
yeah you don't seem like someone it's
always good to have someone like that in
your life whether it's a friend your
wife someone who can say off Jim
someone could say Jim this is not what
you want to do just be that voice of
reason because if not we're like again
we listen to We want to fulfill our
agents expectations and make them happy
okay okay you tend to do that that's
what we do we want to make people happy
um I don't ever see you as someone who
snaps are you someone that can really be
scary when you do snap can you just be
like intense and be like no we're not
doing that
oh yeah no I can be a dick you can be a
dick yeah totally no I mean I um
yeah I mean it's
yeah it's it's you know there's uh
there's the decision I mean I almost
want to go back to the the you know to
the previous question because like here
let me ask you let me answer it this way
okay well you have to understand is also
when my wife had her brain tumor
there was
an expectation that I was done with
touring I was done with acting
my life you know I was going to be the
single father of five children I wasn't
gonna Outsource it so
when she made it through
there was
oh my gosh I can do this a greater
appreciation for stand-up and acting but
the answer is still the same it's still
every three months or every project is
this worth
um
being away you know what I mean or or
um that's like even shows in La I've
never done I you know I turned down all
shows like TV shows in LA and you know I
know you've spent time in Vancouver I
did Peter Pan in Vancouver for four
months during the pandemic where I
couldn't leave
and so like but that's Disney and my
wife was like yeah that's Disney you're
going to do that but like it would I go
up there and do a show for four months I
don't know I don't think I would right
you know I mean yeah